hi there Steve Cochran here I'm sitting
in Palm Springs California the Sun is
beating down on me I'm going to talk
about word-count graded readers and how
many words we need to speak it all has
to do with this whole issue of word
count my conclusions because some of you
want the conclusions up front my
conclusion is that the speak a language
well you need lots of words if you just
want to exchange pleasantries you can do
this with far fewer words fluency means
speaking a language well therefore
fluency means knowing a lot of words
insofar as graded readers and the
significance of word count I find
personally that I like to obviously work
with with easy College sheltered
material for the first few months but I
like to move into meaningful authentic
content that's of interest to me as soon
as possible and this depends on the
language but typically within a few
months now
knowledge those are the conclusions now
let's get into the details first of all
you'll notice that I have what looks
like dirt underneath my nose and this is
because leaving Vancouver after I left
Vancouver a group of people at Lync
decided that they would participate in
this Movember movement which is a sort
of a promotion to raise money for men's
health issues prostate cancer or
whatever and that people involved in
this movement will grow a moustache and
we'll be raising money so at link we've
got a team together we've contributed
some money we're trying to raise money
and we're all growing a moustache I got
a bit of a late start in this but I can
assure you that Alex and and nav in
particular mark they're all sporting
much more significant growth under their
nose than I have so far
anyway and I'm working here outside
without my normal microphone I hope the
sound quality is OK
now the subject of word count comes up
all the time we had a thread at our
format link someone was looking for more
graded material for Russian on our site
we have a vast library of Russian
content lots of beginner material lots
of intermediate material we recently
have obtained permission from echo
Moskvy to put all of their material on
our website
I mean you won't find not in ten books
more material than we have at link yet
still this one learner said you know
there's a gap between the sort of
intermediate and upper intermediate that
the statistics that link show him that
there's over 25% new words in some of
the content that he would like to study
can we please fill the gap and this got
me thinking and then other people
commented about how nice it is to have
graded readers and so forth so on
personally I think it is unrealistic to
expect that you can start with very
simple material and then very gradually
and seamlessly work your way through a
lot of graded readers sheltered texts
embedded texts and always deal with a
very small number of new words I feel if
you did that it would take forever to
learn the number of words that you need
that's why personally I prefer I'm
driven more by my interest in the
subject matter and if there's thirty
forty percent new words so be it
I worked my way through it I do very
this more difficult text content with
easier stuff just to give myself a bit
of a relief but there's a few things to
remember yes it's true that a relatively
small number of words accounts for 70 80
percent of the content in any language
I'm reading a book right now by Steven
Pinker
about the decline of violence in our
society but he mentions in there that
five words I think was aa saw be of and
maybe it or something
accounts for like twenty percent of all
content in English but you can't say
very much with those 20 words there five
words rather and the problem
you have a top thousand words is that it
might account for 75% of any content but
you don't understand much with only
those words so I believe you need quite
a large vocabulary the good thing about
the fact that the most frequent words
account for 70 80 % of any content is
that as you're pursuing content of
interest and acquiring new words at a
rather quicker pace using link for
example we have online dictionaries and
words and phrases save into a database
for review and all the rest of it the
advantage is that as you're pursuing
these new words and I'm always motivated
at link to increase my known word count
that's kind of driving me but it forces
me to regularly review the most frequent
70% so you're always gonna get enough
exposure to those most frequent words so
I guess the conclusion is for those
people who enjoy graded or sheltered
reading you know by all means do what
you like to do but I don't think it's a
condition of learning I don't think it's
necessary personally if I'm gonna read
post or I don't want to read a dumbed
down simplified version of Anna Karenina
in 20 pages before attacking the you
know full version but some people do and
I don't have anything against those
people I'm just saying that we should do
what we want to do but it shouldn't be
held out as a condition that you must
have these graded readers you must
always have no more than 10 percent
unknown words this may be true when
you're reading away from the computer
but typically I build up my vocabulary
very much using link on the computer on
my iPad in which case after a few months
I'm hitting you know authentic material
and a related question is sort of the
converse of this as you often hear the
statement that you know with a very
small number of words you can actually
say a lot and it may be true that with a
limited vocabulary that is active
vocabulary you can express quite a few
thoughts however if you're in a
meaningful conversation with people what
matters sometimes even more is your
ability to understand what they are
saying
and in order to understand what other
people are saying native speakers you
actually need a large vocabulary and if
and I can prove this at link if I go in
and grab from our library a transcript
of a conversation in whatever language
I'm studying there will always be words
they're important words to the
conversation that I don't understand
that are new to me so we do need a large
vocabulary pass evoke every in my
opinion a sort of a defensive measure in
order to be able to understand people in
conversations and of course movies books
newspapers you name it so I am in favor
of working to acquire a large vocabulary
and I think the suggestion that we only
need a small vocabulary in order to be
fluent
I don't agree and then you get these
people say well the definition of fluent
is vague and we don't know what we mean
again I don't agree I think we know very
well what fluid means fluent means
speaking the language
well proficiently now you can say I
speak a certain language quite well
fairly well so that modifies the well so
it's less than well so you can be quite
fluent fairly fluent but if you say I'm
fluent it means I speak the language
well and in order to say that you are
fluent in my view you need a large
vocabulary
what's more you don't not only need a
large vocabulary you need a lot of
exposure to the culture the language the
people - the environment surrounding the
language so all of this takes quite a
long time so to achieve fluency in other
words to speak the language well takes a
long time and requires quite a large
vocabulary in my view the shortest path
to acquiring that vocabulary is not
staying in sheltered reading graded
readers and other sort of classroom or
specially prepared for the learner type
of content after a few months I feel you
have to challenge yourself with the real
thing
the same as is the case with immersion
talking to a teacher in a class
is not immersion immersion is getting
out there and talking to real people who
are going to use a wide range of
vocabulary and you need to have as much
of that as possible so I've kind of
ranged around the subject dealing with
word count graded readers embedded
reading how many words you need to be
fluent what fluency means but it's all
part of the same theme the language that
you are learning is rich and vibrant
there is no shortcut to fluency or being
comfortable in this new environment you
have to put in the time and you have to
make a certain amount of effort and at
times that effort might mean stepping
out of your comfort zone and moving into
the real language environment and with
that if I can move my cursor to where
the stop on this thing is this is the
problem now where am i boy it's kind of
warm here but there's more light outside
than inside but I cannot find my cursor
and so you'll have to bear with me I
might cut this off at the end but where
did that stupid person